for established Western tech companies
the competition makeup is changing at a
rapid pace new customers and competitors
are popping up in emerging markets and
these are the markets that are driving
the strongest economic growth
internationally what are the chances of
Germany getting not from its prized spot
that's a question for bent fan or you're
an executive consultant and professor
what are you advising your clients at
the moment I advise my clients to to be
watchful to look very carefully where
emerging companies are gaining success
are gaining market shares and and to
have a right response for that how
watchful and and how careful do they
have to be every one strategy we see
that the companies like out of China the
tech German companies in the lower
market segments so German companies have
to think about find the right response
which means in many instances to go
local made in Germany will become made
by Germany German companies need
increasingly to establish local
manufacturing and R&D hubs so in
emerging countries so it's not just the
case that they can rest on their laurels
and expect everything to go as it has
there will be a big mistake sometimes
success breeds arrogance and complacency
and this is this CZ issue a formal
afforded klein if we take our viewers
back 150 years it was the UK that was
europe's economic engine not Germany and
Germany was considered to be a copycat
some an economy that produced cheap
versions or cheap products the Germans
change that basically became an
extremely innovative nation how did they
manage to do that as you describe first
say copied but at that stage Germany had
a very had a very good or started to
have a very good university system and a
lot of knowledge then was transferred to
the business sector and that has been
kept or the centuries and that's one of
the key advantages of Germany I could
that be what China is going through
right now yes definitely China is a
serious competitor they watch the rise
of Germany or Japan and the Germany has
to stay in the front as to stay
innovative what are the chances of the
Chinese turning the tables on the
Germans
it's an open race I think the for the
middle stunt companies I'm very
optimistic they are active in the
growing regions the address the
so-called megatrends energy efficiency
medical technology things like that and
they are very flexible a key challenge
will be the business environment as you
well know we have democratic challenges
in Germany and we need young people in
the science and engineering fields and
we need to to foster increasing
immigration demographic changes there's
something that creep up or an economy
there's an economy have to then be very
quick at adapting to challenge as the
Duke pop up yes and that's that's the
key to adjust and and to find new
solution and again the middle stunt
those are family-owned companies they
are long-term oriented and very flexible
so that's I think one of the key
advantage so they've always find a
solution there they are very creative so
again not resting on your laurels Japan
was another example in Asia if we can
stay there for a moment tell me more
about what you thought was going to
happen with Japan at one stage very good
example if you go back read the books
about Japan they were supposed to lead
the world in 99 98 that didn't happen
one of the key advantage of also called
total quality management and this was
increasingly adapted by country by
companies from Germany or or zs both the
Japanese companies lost search they are
still good but they are not the dominant
competitor okay so it's all about
adapting history can repeat itself mr.
van or thank you very much for joining
us well movie